that's like getting into any character i
think
it's it is that three months or two
months before
that you're just doing everything for
muscle memory you're just letting like
when i did paulie like just sitting in
that i would take a shower
paulie on uh the many saints of newark
which is now on hbo hbo max which you
can watch which you guys got to check
out but learning those mannerisms it was
just i had to live with them over and
over again so once i got to set with all
the and all the blah blah i didn't
have to think about those body or my
mannerisms or the lines or the the way
he spoke his cadence and all that stuff
but you but you did like you knew this
guy you met this guy who played i only
met him finally uh or tony uh he was
just on set one day and stuff like that
but it was all before i was just like so
we had a youtube video oh you watch
youtube interviews and i like i was like
i gotta figure out who tony is not not
paulie walnuts you know right because
obviously i think
the line between tony and paulie are is
very thin what's he like uh you're doing
it all wrong what the i do that
what are you doing no not at all how you
doing hey thanks for doing this
how cool is this like kind of like think
to the side you always talk to the side
of his mouth with this lisp so that's
what you did yeah
do that again that was cool how you did
that
you just i know i'm doing like a bill
murray from caddysha it was two years
ago i did this thing so it's like really
it just came out now
muscle memory man
right wow i think i don't know so what
did you just kind of i don't know he had
this thing and i just saw the way his
mouth sat
this far the best line i ever heard was
like i love that guck sucker like a
brother and then he me in the ass
is that paul one of the lines no that's
just him from the show and i was just
like
david chase writing that line is
brilliant because like it's just the
most absurd absurd line when you
audition for this i read somewhere that
you didn't even like you never had seen
sopranos no i never
no i had never seen it and i auditioned
for a different character in the film
and i didn't get it i failed i didn't
get it did they just offer you the other
role and they were like hey would you be
interested in
trying this route and i was like okay
and then i did you audition for that no
i didn't you didn't not that time no but
because i auditioned for another
character so you can't asset like
knowing what you're going to do and
sometimes that's hard when you get an
offer and you get on set and you're
starting to do this mouth thing like you
know doing this well it's okay there's
like a road map when you have to
the character kind of already existed so
you're just
kind of following but they were excited
to see what you were bringing to no they
were not they hated me
[Laughter]
get out get out oh it was challenging it
was what do you mean
uh it was a challenging one that's all i
can say you could just say it was a
challenging role
no
it was the other stuff was challenging
it was just challenging being on set
yeah it was just like there was a lot of
cooks
uh i i'm gonna leave this you could
leave that alone i could leave it alone
but overall did you love the other
actors you were oh that's the thing like
the crew the guy the crew and the the
other actors were fantastic world
theater guys so we had like this we we
had uh what was it not nomenclatures
where you could speak the same language
and we could talk about and the trust in
the space was wonderful because everyone
is doing some weird right you know
and
yeah but how do you trust yourself when
you're the people around you are not
kind of like you're like you're just
doing your lines you're reading them
you're acting them out you're trusting
yourself is it hard to trust yourself
when there's some chaos going on
whatever that was of course of course so
you just slick with it no no you just
let go man what are you going to do
you're there you're going to do what
you're going to such a good attitude
yeah billy magnuson
you